but you don't believe in retirement you
don't believe in an end
i don't but i also think it's a very
personal journey like when i travel i
meet a 69 year old dude in florida
during downtime and i'll get into
chatting and i'm pumped for that guy's
like i've been wrapped it up five years
ago i'm down here i've got my you know
metal detector in the sand i'm fishing i
don't know why i love the idea of
somebody who really loves fishing ten
hours a day goes home watches his sports
that's my goal bro that's amazing like
honestly on some real [ __ ] there's a big
part of me that envies that there's a
big part of me that goes man i wish my
wiring was a little bit different cause
that sounds fresh but you can do it but
i don't want to i can tell you right now
like if you open me up right now and
read my chemicals i want to [ __ ] do
this for the rest of my life i like it
too much comma if i wake up at 71 and
just out of nowhere you know how some
people just do that like i do want to
just fish i'm very comfortable in fully
following who i am